[Music]
i never wanted to be
a businessman or being in fashion as the
business grow
more and more people coming in and i
struggled with aligning the company
in the same way that we communicated i
wonder how
would my grandfather feel if he saw what
i did to his business today
the process was difficult trying to
change a very traditional business
can you imagine experiencing the zoo
without actually being in the zoo
most singaporeans they come to our zoo
one a year how do we make our brand
relevant in their everyday lives i think
design is
about telling a story to create
something that's intangible
in life if you don't have things like
that it removes the romance of life like
life is just going to be very mundane if
every spoon of rice you eat from a
styrofoam box
is toxic to your health and takes days
away from your lifespan
but you still eat from it should we fix
this problem through design